.
THEY ARE NOT THE FRIENDS OF
ANYONE IN THIS COUNTRY, THEY ARE
DANGEROUS.
THAT'S OBVIOUS.
IN THE MEANTIME, WE'RE HAPPY TO
HAVE ONE OF THE VERY FEW PEOPLE
IN AMERICAN JOURNALISM WHO
UNDERSTOOD EXACTLY WHAT WAS
GOING ON LONG BEFORE MOST OF US
DID AND WROTE ABOUT IT
EXTENSIVELY.
GLENN GREENWALD, A FREQUENT
GUEST OF THE SHOW, THANKS SO
MUCH FOR COMING ON.
I THINK THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
LEVELS HERE, I HAVE LEARNED IN
THE LAST WEEK THAT IN WASHINGTON
THE FACT THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS READING OUR EMAILS
IS NO BIG DEAL AND YOU'RE LIKE A
NUTCASE FOR EVEN NOTING IT OR
BEING BOTHERED BY IT, YOU SHOULD
HAVE NO EXPECT TATIAN OF PRIVACY
WHATSOEVER BUT I THINK, AND YOU
WOULD NO, THE FEDERAL LAW IS
PRETTY CLEAR ON THIS.
IF NSA CAPTURES INFORMATION SENT
PRIVATELY BY THE AMERICAN
CITIZEN THEY HAVE TO KEEP THAT
CITIZEN'S IDENTITY SECRET UNLESS
THEY GO THROUGH A PROCESS TO
"UNMASK" IT.
IT SEEMS VERY CLEAR THEY DID
EXACTLY WHAT THEY ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO DO.
>> YEAH.
I THINK THERE'S TWO IMPORTANT
COMPONENTS.
ONE IS THE FIRST ONE THAT YOU
JUST REFERENCED, WHICH IS THAT
IF THEY WERE DOING THIS
PERFECTLY LEGALLY, MEANING THEY
INTERCEPTED YOUR EMAIL
COMMUNICATIONS WITH LEGAL
AUTHORITY BECAUSE YOU ARE
TALKING EITHER TO THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT WHICH THEY ALL
BEASLEY ARE ALLOWED TO SPY ON,
OR TO A TARGET IN THE
UNITED STATES -- THEY LEARNED
THAT WAY THAT YOU ARE
COMMUNICATING WITH THE RUSSIANS
ABOUT THE POSSIBILITY OF AN
INTERVIEW WITH PUTIN, THEY HAVE
THE LEGAL OBLIGATION TO CONCEAL
YOUR IDENTITY AND MAKE SURE THAT
NOBODY KNOWS THAT YOU WERE THE
ONE THAT WAS SPEAKING TO THE
RUSSIANS, THE INTELLIGENCE THAT
THEY CARE ABOUT IS THAT THE
RUSSIANS WERE DOING SOMETHING,
NOT WITH WHOM THEY WERE
SPEAKING, SO CLEARLY THERE WAS
EITHER A FAILURE TO HIDE YOUR
IDENTITY AS REQUIRED BY LAW,
WHICH IS ILLEGAL, OR AN ATTEMPT
TO UNMASK IT AFTER IT WAS
MINIMIZED, WHICH ALSO WOULD BE A
CRIME GIVEN THAT THERE IS NO
NATIONAL SECURITY JUSTIFICATION
FOR DOING IT.
THERE'S SOMETHING MUCH MORE
SERIOUS, TUCKER, WHICH IS WHEN
THE NSA SPIES ON AMERICAN
CITIZENS SPEAKING TO FOREIGN
NATIONALS AND FOREIGN OFFICIALS,
EVEN WHEN IT'S LEGAL, THAT'S A
VERY GRAVE POWER, SO THERE'S
LIMITS ON WHAT THEY CAN DO WITH
THAT.
IT IS ONE OF THE GREATEST CRIMES
IN THE U.S. CODE FOR THE NSA TO
LEAK THE CONTENTS OF
COMMUNICATIONS THAT IT
INTERCEPTS BETWEEN A FOREIGN
OFFICIAL AND AN AMERICAN
CITIZEN.
AND I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT GOT OVERLOOKED IS THAT IN
2017, WHEN GENERAL FLYNN, WHO
WAS IN THE CROSSHAIRS OF THE
ENTIRE DEEP STATE UNDER OBAMA,
WAS SPEAKING WITH
AMBASSADOR KISLYAK, THEY LEAKED
THE CONTENTS OF THAT
COMMUNICATION, INTERCEPTED KEY
MEDICATIONS BETWEEN A RUSSIAN
OFFICIAL AND INCOMING NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR TO
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
NOT ONLY DON'T WE KNOW WHO DID
THE LEAKING, NO ONE CARES
BECAUSE THEY HATE GENERAL FLYNN,
HE'S NOT THEIR IDEOLOGY AND
THEREFORE THEY THINK IT'S
JUSTIFIED.
THAT'S THE REACTION HERE.
OH, IT'S TUCKER CARLSON, HE'S A
CONSERVATIVE, WE DON'T LIKE HIM
AND SO WE DON'T EVEN CARE IF THE
NSA WAS DOING THIS, BUT IT IS
ILLEGAL TO DO EITHER OF THOSE
TWO THINGS.
>> Tucker: AND IT'S NOT AN
ATTACK ON FLYNN OR ANYTHING BUT
LIKE SO MANY PEOPLE HE WAS UNDER
ATTACK AND HE WENT ON THE
DEFENSIVE AND THEN HE REMAINED
SILENT AND DIDN'T ARTICULATE HIS
OWN CASE AND MAYBE HIS LAWYERS
TOLD HIM NOT TO OR SOMETHING,
BUT IF YOU WERE PERSISTENT
INDEPENDENT, LOOK, YOU MAY NOT
LIKE MY POLITICS, BUT YOU'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO VIOLATE MY RIGHTS AND
BREAK THE LAW.
I MEAN, I WONDER IF YOU COULD
FORCE THEM TO ADMIT WHAT
HAPPENED AND THEN YOU COULD
FORCE SOME ACCOUNT ABILITY.
I MEAN, NO ONE IN HIS AGENCIES,
BRENNAN, CLAPPER, THEY LIED
UNDER OATH BEFORE CONGRESS.
NOBODY CARES, NOBODY DOES
ANYTHING.
COULD YOU ACTUALLY FORCE THE
SYSTEM TO HOLD THESE
UNACCOUNTABLE LEADERS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR ONCE?
>> THE PROBLEM IS THERE ARE SO
MANY DOCTRINES THAT THE DASH THE
SECURITY STATE HAS EXISTED SINCE
THE END OF WORLD WAR II.
THEY'VE BEEN OPERATING IN SECRET
AND WITH NO DEMOCRATIC
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR EIGHT OR NINE
DECADES NOW.
DWIGHT EISENHOWER WHEN HE LEFT
OFFICE WARNED THE COUNTRY ABOUT
THE DANGERS THAT THEY POSE, SO,
SO MANY TIMES WHEN PEOPLE HAVE
GONE TO SUE THE NSA FOR
ILLEGALLY SPYING ON THEM THEY
HAVE DOCTRINES THAT THEY USE
THAT WILL SAY IT'S TOO SECRET,
WE CAN'T HAVE COURTS LOOKING
INTO WHAT WE DID, BECAUSE THAT
WILL JEOPARDIZE NATIONAL
SECURITY AND THEN COURTS
DISMISSED THE LAWSUIT, OR THEY
WILL SAY TUCKER CARLSON CAN'T
PROVE THAT WE ACTUALLY SPIED ON
HIM, THEREFORE HE HAS NO
STANDING TO SUE AND COURTS WILL
DISMISS THAT AS WELL.
THE REMEDY HERE IS FOR
CONGRESS -- IT'S CONGRESS'
RESPONSIBILITY TO EXERCISE
OVERSIGHT HOW THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH SPIES ON PEOPLE AND FOR
SO LONG CONGRESS HAS BEEN EITHER
AFRAID OF THE NSA AND THE CIA OR
WORSE, SUBSERVIENT TO THEM, AND
YOU'RE RIGHT, IT HAS BEEN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY ALONG WITH
DEMOCRATS THAT HAS LONG
VENERATED THESE AGENCIES AND
ONLY UNDER TRUMPETED THEY START
TO REALIZE ACTUALLY THESE
AGENCIES INTERFERE IN OUR
POLITICS AND THREATEN OUR
DEMOCRACY AND REALLY PERNICIOUS
WAYS AND THAT THEY NEED TO TAKE
THAT KNOWLEDGE THAT THEY LEARNED
OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS AND USE
IT TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF WHAT
HAPPENED HERE.
>> Tucker: SO I SPOKE TO --
THIS IS NOT SPECULATION, THIS IS
A CONVERSATION I HAD PERSONALLY
FACE-TO-FACE WITH SOMEONE I
THOUGHT WAS A VERY POWERFUL
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE THAT
OVERSEES THE INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES IN CONGRESS.
I CAN'T BE MORE SPECIFIC.
IF TWO YEARS AGO TOLD ME TO MY
FACE THAT HIS COMMUNICATIONS
WERE BEING MONITORED BY THE
INTEL AGENCIES, THE ONES THAT HE
WAS SUPPOSED TO BE OVERSEEING
AND THAT HE DIDN'T DARE TEXT ME
BECAUSE HE KNEW THEY WERE
READING HIS TEXT AND I THOUGHT
TO MYSELF THE SYSTEM IS COMPLETE
WE DYSFUNCTIONAL.
IF THE PERSON IS SUPPOSED TO BE
HOLDING THEM ACCOUNTABLE AS OF
RIGHT OF THEM, THEN WHO'S IN
CHARGE OR?
IT SOUNDS LIKE THEY ARE.
>> WE LEARNED -- THIS WAS ONE OF
THE BIG SCANDALS OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION'S, WHEN THEY WERE
INVESTIGATING THE CIA AND THEIR
ROLE IN THE INTERROGATION
PROGRAM AT GUANTANAMO AND
ELSEWHERE, JOHN BRENNAN, CIA,
SPIED ON THE LEADER OF THAT
SENATE INVESTIGATION, WHICH WAS
DIANNE FEINSTEIN.
THE CIA WAS SPYING ON THE SENATE
AS THE SENATE WAS INVESTIGATING
THE CIA.
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT EXCHANGE --
I THINK I TALKED ABOUT THIS ON
YOUR SHOW BEFORE, WAS THREE DAYS
BEFORE TRUMP WAS INAUGURATED,
CHUCK SCHUMER WENT ON THE RACHEL
MADDOW SHOW AND SHE WAS VERY
UPSET THAT TRUMP WAS INSULTING
THE CIA BECAUSE SHE LOVES THE
CIA AND CHUCK SCHUMER SAID THE
THING YOU'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO SAY
ALOUD, WHICH IS TRUMP IS BEING
STUPID BECAUSE EVERYONE KNOWS
THAT IF YOU CHALLENGE THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY, THEY
HAVE SIX DIFFERENT WAYS TO
SUNDAY TO GET BACK AT YOU AND
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THEY
PROCEEDED TO DO OVER THE NEXT
FOUR YEARS, UNDERMINE HIS
ADMINISTRATION.
PEOPLE IN WASHINGTON ARE
PETRIFIED OF THE SECURITY STATE
AND THAT'S WHY THEY EXIST WITH
NO DEMOCRATIC ACCOUNT ABILITY.
>> Tucker: WELL, WE HAVE TO
PUSH BACK.
IF THEY FIND A METH LAB IN MY
BASEMENT, IT'S NOT REAL, JUST SO